hey welcome Felix here I have found the
strangest fetish online sneezing videos
that's right everybody
sneezing videos is sweeping the nation
is your kid watching sneezing videos on
YouTube you better watch out YouTube is
a dangerous plight apparently it's
really popular really really popular so
popular that from now on big
announcement I have become a sneezing
Channel
let's look at some sneezing people oh
[ __ ] that's a lot of sneezes how does
she do it
incredible how does she do that thing
with her notes I've never seen anything
like it
you can follow her on Instagram sneeze
girl 1 for 3 come up with that I'm gonna
be sneeze girl
ah [ __ ] was taken it's private come on
May come on I need to see them sneezes
now the favorite part of these sneezing
videos is the comments they're
absolutely [ __ ] up nuts but horribly
horribly hot no name but very very
pretty awesome sneezes really sexy Rick
Sanders he just liked a couple videos he
liked this one and on the other sneezing
one all these like videos are related to
sneezing and allergies 10 hours of
sneezing this is weird dude this guy is
weird
that's her hundred and fifty fourth
sneeze what are these chem girls I like
apologetic sneezers what's the most
viewed sneeze beautiful girls quadruple
sneeze my god must see this
[Music]
I love this one because it's just a guy
trying to play a guitar but it keeps
sneezing and he's just getting genuinely
pissed off about it he just gave up
sneezing can change lives
it's not just a fetish but it's also a
fetish bless you for all your sneezes
handsome cute sneezes by the way even
girls like sneezes please make sure so
hot bless you you are so handsome are
you telling me right now that all I have
to do is sneeze and women will like me
my declining female demographic will
finally return if I sneeze well the
choice is obvious I need to figure out
how to sneeze some demand what's that
cute what's that did I seem real wait
what what but what is that what is that
PewDiePie sneeze compilation what the
ten thousand News you can thank me later
there's two of them holy [ __ ] these are
like super old videos these are so old
how old are you what sorry
make him find you I got it
that one was cute how did they find all
these they must go through like hundred
so much [ __ ] videos so many videos I
have thousands of videos kind of want
that on my son boys wait jack has one
what the [ __ ] I bet I have way cuter
sneeze than Jack by the way yeah confirm
that [ __ ] was that
lame wait ken has a [ __ ] sneeze holy
[ __ ] a triple sneeze
not bad Ken I may have a bit of respect
left for you after all right cry cry
there's every [ __ ] youtuber ever as a
sneezing compilation oh [ __ ] that you
moved down there they definitely moved
down there yeah I'd [ __ ] that sneeze I'd
[ __ ] me I [ __ ] it
sorry might say I'm over you now wait
you guys better not be perverts over my
destiny Singh no no in the piece and
acid we put little plans around I can't
wait
don't worry I will do it even her sneeze
is sexy what the [ __ ]
another's what the [ __ ] is this Channel
there's even a whole science around
sneezing I don't know if you guys
realize this but it's it's pretty
interesting let's break down the Tosh's
cough shall we well they're testing
what's grosser a sneeze or a cough a
cough projected thousands of bacteria up
to 7 feet away yeah it's my face at 55
miles per hour I can feel her phlegm
drying on my 38 well it's 38 me I'm kind
of into that I let girls sneeze on me
sorry I might say I don't watch this
video much I would let girls sneeze on
me please this video has this video has
converted me alright how much is in the
sneeze now what's weirder is reacting
through this [ __ ] sneezing is gross get
this ride you've perverts and stop
looking at my girlfriend sneezing I
don't like it what that's right that's
right daddy of five you're so right so
if you ever have to sneeze in public
here's what you do the Dracula sneeze no
it's a DAB it's a it's a DAB so if
you're spreading germs sneezing even
when covering your mouth and sneezing
into your elbow is there anything you
can do but grab a tissue believe it or
not with mark is sneezing right into the
tissue we found nothing getting through
nothing well I still stand by the dab
wait what
twelve-year-old sneezes 12,000 times per
day there's always some weird fetishes
per day
Gio Benitez has her story for us oh [ __ ]
are you kidding me
for twelve-year-old Katelyn Thornley
whoa whoa whoa whoa well ago Katelyn
began sneezing and she hasn't stopped
I feel bad for her it kind of started
and just like little spurts you know it
was like just a few sneezes here and
there but by the time I went to battered
sneeze 30 times that night Katelyn now
averaging about 20 sneezes per minute
it's really painful and so far doctors
the Texas Children's Hospital in Houston
haven't been able to figure out exactly
what is causing the oh my god whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa oh my god that so many
snakes Reed well I'm gonna hell after I
die but she sounds like a stray
well it's time for you and III know it's
time to pull out the sneeze I realized
all I need to do is pull out a really
good sneeze I don't know if you noticed
but they've all been fake sneezes I know
I can fake him really well but let's do
a genuine sneeze here together let's see
if we can both do it together I I came
prepared I have one of these I'm going
to stick it up my no wait my nose
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
subscribe